[Music]
and rude altering news all right good
look submitted by tyka on JK news yeah
we need to bring them my cry though yeah
and then it kind of ruins the whole
thing what the baby do is what should
there be baby I could see it on the vlog
good that's it that's all we do maybe I
should have them in that little carrier
thing and then maybe I'll say you're
[ __ ] our baby Oh facing the other way
I have to face me
I think the way like three months or
something to like turn around cuz he'll
just be like so they make it where the
heads right here they do all this [ __ ]
yeah can barely move their head there at
the programming stage right now
yeah their world is just their mouth all
right forget enough upvotes will replace
Julia what I could if this video hits a
million views we'll see how how bad you
guys really want see him
researchers have examined the ways in
which airplane travel messes with your
mind and body airplane travel messes
with your mind definitely have you been
on like a 20-hour flight yes my mind
like breaks around our 12 I'm like I
can't do it I'm jumping out the [ __ ]
window where are you going I was going
up to Indonesia to go to we were to bali
did you any transfers or I mean any yeah
we with a layover in Japan it was like
it was so hilarious because we get off
the airplane and I'm not even kidding me
they're getting you like right next to a
Hello Kitty store well they do have a
Sanrio wait was it night or was it
Haneda yeah yeah
yeah yeah who was that it was that one I
mean I pretty sure all of them have
[ __ ] Hello Kitty in them right inside
the airport yeah there's like that
international ones have like malls
inside the airport yeah they do that's
what that's what this one yeah and nine
is looked at first like walking off like
there's a Hello Kitty store I was like
this is halay it's like I've heard
they're obsessed with Hello Kitty over
there but by god yeah plain that all has
painted help she's amazing
even though food is he lucky everything
no they had a Hello Kitty restaurant in
them it was like Hello Kitty burger
something is weird
Japan is amazing it was great no it was
awesome yeah so they're saying here is
do you guys feel like you're you just
feel different when you fly yeah I feel
great I feel like [ __ ] for like three
days after I fly I'm Way I'm with you
although I do do but usually because I
drink the entire time I was looking it
up and I think I have like maybe a
weird-shaped sinuses or something smells
looking that up and then uh cuz when I
fly the minute the plane takes off I get
crazy pressure here yeah and it's and
I'll take headache medicine and doesn't
do anything and then so what I found
found out it's just crazy congestion
like in my sinuses so I think it someone
told me or recommended me to take
sudafed cuz decongestants I haven't
tried that yet but I'll try that next
night but because of that like I just
feel like shift like the next three days
so usually as soon as I get off the
plane I try to like work out like a
break a sweat take a hot shower damn
that sucks I just sleep even if it's 45
minutes I given if it's to Vegas really
yeah it's the air pressure yeah the
minute I go up there I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] I got no wonder
you don't like planes that much yeah I
cannot sleep on a plane I cannot sleep
on one you can sleep no I could sleep
like a baby especially on takeoff I feel
usually bit like a baby anywhere though
[Laughter]
yeah because they're saying that the the
air pressure is similar to being on top
of a an 8000 foot high mountain so how
do you solve that well I'm not sure how
to solve that this whole article is just
talking about like how flying really
messes with everything so for example
they're saying that the reduced air
pressure on airline flights can reduce
the amount of oxygen and each passenger
in the blood from 6 to 25% maybe I like
oh yeah 25% less oxygen in your blood
yes that sounds like a lot yeah so
they're saying that if you were in a
hospital setting they would immediately
give you artificial like oxygen if it
drop that much already
yeah but then this is something that's
common in airplanes so they don't pump
oxygen into the they do oh they do but
it's there's still a lot of like you
know he's still decreasing odds dinner
the airs been yeah maybe that's why I
get nice and sleepy and calm because
you're like yeah they're saying it's
called
hypoxia which is a divergence E and
oxygen and it could alter your ability
to think clearly and like the way you
feel and I just it alters you completely
buddy my twin hypoxic while he was going
skydiving he just collapsed in the plane
just like passed out in them so he
didn't get a chance to jump out he did
jump out after they good they revived
him and he was like I'm jumping Hayter
my buddy Richard Ryan he's a u-tube guy
he's crazy man that's awesome yeah he he
yeah he hopefull on collapsed and then
he gets up he's just a wild man like
that that's cool so yeah they're just
talking about that and like it changes
your memory
it could also changes your memory yeah
like it it makes changes into your
memory somehow like the pressure the
oxygen levels so you remember different
things no no like it rewrites the memory
if this could realize some trauma I
Maggie I'm gonna fly a little bit more
this is some good [ __ ] or is it like
because there's a lack of oxygen your
mind is running a little bit slower so
that like it takes longer for it yeah
exactly and then also I gotta remember
my flight that's why I don't want I
don't want to remember myself I won't
watch the conception on the flight
because like I'm already slow enough I
don't need to [ __ ] you know have a
headache while I'm watching the goddamn
movie do you guys feel like you get
extra sensitive when you're on an
airplane and watching like a sad movie
sensitive to what I'm so emotional
because apparently that's a really
common thing a lot of people that fly
they find themselves to be more
emotional and they cry I cried every
movie anyways but that's because they
have they have a screaming baby next to
him or some [ __ ] there's a lot of
factors that if I cried on the fly it's
because I was like leaving this guy yeah
they're saying that that's one factor
too Oh
like leaving your loved one yeah or the
excitement for a trip it could be a
happy cry right I've never been that
excited for literally anything no it's
not like a direct like you've done that
don't have you cried because you're so
excited to go to a trip like when you're
headed to Paris to get married no yeah
I'm always excited on the plane to go
somewhere and then I get hit with this
headache and I'm like why am I so
excited about this your hurts I mean you
cry go to that no no try take all kinds
of medicines anything did you were you
unaware of it so you're just like kind
of going and you're like [ __ ] why do I
have allergies or whatever you didn't
know any because we flew up I know I
just thought everyone had it but then
the more I thought the more I found out
no one else so you just live with the
pain yeah and then because never once
did you complain when we were like
flying or anything we did a lot of shows
every spring we would fly out every
weekend
and I'm over here like ooh did you watch
that movie like yeah I had no idea
you're [ __ ] suffering you know yeah
you're just like my first couple of days
of hawaii's always yeah I'm super I love
that and I'm always like [ __ ] trying
to go like this like massage it oh well
yeah I mean like you don't get the you
don't let pain get in the way you're fun
though I try not to are you sniffling a
lot no I I don't it's not like a runny
nose
it's just imagine like someone's like
pressing here like pressing here like
pressing here and it just feels like a
lot of pressure and then I guess the
stuff that's in Tylenol or cedron
doesn't relieve that pressure it has to
be decongestant or something like that
yeah that feels uncomfortable yeah but
they're also saying that you fall asleep
easier it's not directly it's not a
direct effect from the loss of oxygen
but it does contribute to you sleeping
easier I do fall asleep easier to on the
takeoff I fall asleep and I wake up
good is yours it's yours like that bad -
yeah pretty much I just feel like [ __ ]
when I apply that's unhooks yeah that
was the same that in the airplane
there's a very low humidity level so
that's why your nose gets really dry and
and then they also keep the cabin really
cold like about 50 degrees Fahrenheit in
order to like cool off like all the the
body heat from the humans and then like
the TV screen there's just a lot of heat
so then that's why they keep the
airplane that cold they're also saying
that like another effect of low air
pressure is that the human night vision
deteriorates by five to 10% in altitudes
of just 5,000 feet so that [ __ ]
nightmare when you see things at night
like when it's dark
that's [ __ ] day that's so dope well is
it like a permanent deterioration or is
it just like temporary while you're
flying because of the pressure yeah the
lower pressure this stuff matters
because I don't need the lights I don't
need memory I don't need all that what
I'm flying
you don't mean there's also license a
plane to life like like if you can't see
just press the buttons I go it's I've
never I don't know none of these things
sound like problems to me well also well
it's not really a problem is just
they're they're just like oh this is
interesting this happens to your body
when you fly it's more like that
approach I also think too that the
combination of low air pressure and
humidity can reduce the sensitivity of
your taste buds to salt and sweet by up
to 30% the hell is this this could be
real
that's why airplane food tastes like
[ __ ] exactly and then I'm going to put
more likely yeah exactly that can they
explain why I always have a boner on a
fly watch that that is true I always
have one always its my dear I never
don't have a boner employee you can
maintain our boner to both I thought I
was gonna die yeah
no for real I had a bar it's a it's a
random boner attack and I mean it comes
and goes but it's just and then I
uncontrollably started coming
uncontrollably it was terrible mister
worst things ever happened to me
Oh sod never been that sad that you guys
are on control be calm before look is
like I'm sleeping here for like ten to
twelve hours right I don't have a boner
but I'm sitting in the airplane chair
and also have a random boner are you
guys I was farts are definitely fart on
me I know I get extra gassy and that's
another effect that's another effect of
the whole like air pressure yeah as a
man who knows nothing of science right
and the nose the same that your smell
gets worse like you're you lose your
sense of smell that's why the food
tastes like [ __ ] but it's also a good
thing thank God I want to smell people
exactly because everyone's farting
around you don't want to smell that it's
also a good thing because the food
tastes like [ __ ] you know the thing that
does bother me though is I get
dehydrated like a [ __ ] I got a
drink so much water cuz one time I fell
asleep with my mouth open and I woke up
like everyone's sleeping come up and
they give you this little [ __ ] Cup
it's like it's half full it's half full
this [ __ ] man I'm walking walk back
there I just I just stood there while
she kept pouring it I was like drinking
my favorite thing I was gonna soda and
they're like they're like oh um there
you go and like oh do you want the can
I'm like yeah I want the can I've been
on your for eight hours I'll see you in
another eight hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode did you love
it I know you did but guess what you can
also follow us on our personal social
media accounts with the links in the
description box below so both follow all
of us now to watch more videos check
them out up there
[Music]